who's this this this is Hugh Grant
this is Matthew McConaughey and we are
about to play what happens next for lad
Bible and a sensational so we've got a
golf ball it looks to be what happens
next
does he get the ball in the hole yes no
I mean yes that's why you what that's it
well Matthew share China what happens
the kid calls Santa a twit [ __ ] be the
kid poos himself an excitement at the
letter C the kid person to YouTube so I
believe the kid calls Santa twit well a
letter bomb and I'm shocked at you're
using this yeah spacebar didn't give the
in spacebar spacebar let it play it says
it's almost Christmas and I have no
noise that you have been fairly good
this year your name is on my place it
must here and the law school my else and
working hard
okay so we've got a bloke here yeah
leading dance with a couple of dancing
girls behind him and he's there in
synchronicity would be like the Macarena
or something but I've never heard this
song what happened both girls one of the
sort honestly they had Strauss's fall
down
the guy jumps and smacks his hello roof
see I get season let's hope to see
[Music]
you guys fans over there in the
background just a straight fall gee
where'd you find these are they on the
lad Bible yeah who falls in the river
the man the woman both of them is what I
say he's gonna be extra valiant to try
and help around do it and she goes full
immersion my bad
next all right so he's taking a whiz he
drops his phone into his own urine be
the guy's phone punches the man see got
his phone does an incredible impression
of Donald Trump let's go with C I'm
going B picks it up out of the urinal
it's better than when you're sitting
already sold-out film this is you grant
this is my people gonna hate that was
what happens next
on lad
[Music]
you